WE BELIEVE IN FREEDOM OF SPEECH,
EXPRESSION.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN BOYCOTTS.
I WANT ALL VOICES TO BE HEARD.
BUSY NEXT TONIGHT.
DEMOCRATS ARE VERY ANXIOUS,
JERRY NADLER ALL OF A SUDDEN IS
BEGINNING TO SWEAT.
THEY COWARDLY SCHIFF?
HE'S LOOKING MORE SHIFTY THAN HE
USUALLY IS.
HE'S THE ONLY GUY CAUGHT ON TAPE
COLLUDING WITH RUSSIANS.
TELL US WHAT YOU HAVE...
"WE'VE GOT NAKED PICS...
THAT IDIOT, HE THOUGHT HE WAS
GETTING INTEL.
LET'S INVESTIGATE THAT GUY.
THE INFIGHTING BETWEEN PELOSI,
HERETICAL BASE IS GETTING
AND THE FRINGE CANDIDATES
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT ARE MORE
THAN SCARY, THEY ARE MORE THAN
LESS THAN INSPIRING, THEIR IDEAS
ARE CHILLING, BUT THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY TONIGHT ARE IN SHAMBLES
AND FOR GOOD REASON.
A MULTIYEAR ARC RUSSIAN
COLLUSION HOAX WAS A FAILURE.
TRUMP WINNING HAPPENED.
BY THE WAY, LOOK AT HIS
PRESIDENCY.
A HUGE SUCCESS.
THANK GOODNESS, THANK GOD, THE
ECONOMY IS BOOMING.
THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN,
NEARLY 7 MILLION AMERICANS OFF
OF FOOD STAMPS, AS MANY OUT OF
POVERTY.
AND WE HAVE THE LOWEST
UNEMPLOYMENT, THE BEST
EMPLOYMENT SITUATION SINCE 1969.
YES, PEOPLE LEFT BEHIND.
EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC ARE DOING
BETTER, SETTING RECORD LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THE DEMOCRATS?
THEY ARE PLAYING, I GUESS,
WHATEVER THEY ALWAYS DO, GAMES.
THEY AREN'T DOING ANYTHING TO
HELP THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY AGENDA
THAT'S GOING TO SOLVE OUR
PROBLEMS.
IT'S A CARD THEY KEEP PLAYING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
WE INVESTIGATE A COUPLE OF TIMES
CAN WE GET WHAT WE WANT.
IT DOESN'T WORK THAT WAY.
DESPERATE EFFORT TO KEEP THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX, THE
CONSPIRACY THEORY ALIVE FOR AS
LONG AS POSSIBLE?
CHAIRMAN JERRY NADLER, THE GYM
FERRY COMMITTEE, THE INTEL
CHAIR, ADAM "THE COWARDLY"
SCHIFF ARE FORCING BOB MUELLER
TO TESTIFY IN PUBLIC ON
CAPITOL HILL AND HE SAID HE
DIDN'T WANT TO DO IT AND HE'S
GOING TO STICK TO THE REPORT.
WE WILL SEE NEXT WEDNESDAY.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO WORK
OUT THE WAY THEY THINK.
I'M ALMOST CERTAIN.
ACCORDING TO THE AP, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE BEGINNING TO
LISTEN TO HANNITY.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT NEXT
WEDNESDAY'S HEARING.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT IT.
THEY SHOULD BE.
ROBERT MUELLER LONG SAID THAT
THE REPORT WILL SPEAK FOR
ITSELF.
ZERO CHARGES FOR OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE AND IT WAS DECIDED AS IT
SHOULD BE A SPECIAL COUNSEL
LOSS, THEY ACTUALLY READ IT, THE
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
OFFICE OF THE LEGAL COUNSEL.
THOSE QUESTIONS HAVE ALL BEEN
THOROUGHLY ANSWERED IN THE
EXHAUSTED, FRANKLY POLITICAL,
POORLY WRITTEN, HORRIBLY LAW
BASED, 448 PAGE REPORT.
MEANWHILE, REPUBLICANS SHOULD
FOCUS ON THE LITANY OF WHAT OUR
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS THAT WE
HAVE PREVIEWED ON THIS PROGRAM
LAST NIGHT, WE ARE GOING TO DO A
FULL HOUR TOMORROW NIGHT.
THE POLITICAL BIAS,
PROSECUTORIAL MISCONDUCT,
CONFLICT OF INTEREST, SO MANY
CRUCIAL TOPICS WILL GET THE
ATTENTION THEY DESERVE.
NOT GOING TO COME FROM THE
REPUBLICANS ON THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S COMING FOR THAT COMES AS
THE DEMOCRATS 'FRENZIED CALLS
FOR IMPEACHMENTS, THEY ARE
ACTUALLY GOING QUIET.
LOOK AT THIS FROM "POLITICO,"
THE PROMINENT HOUSE ADVOCATES
ACKNOWLEDGE THE PUSH HAS SLOWED
TO A STANDSTILL.
THAT MEANS, IF YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD, GREAT.
BUT THAT'S GOING TO GUARANTEE
TRUMP'S REELECTION AND THE
REPUBLICANS GET CONTROL OF THE
HOUSE AND SENATE AND WE CAN
SOLVE MORE OF AMERICA'S PROBLEMS
AND HELP THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND
WOMEN EVEN MORE BECOME RICHER,
RAISE THE STANDARD OF LIVING,
AND BECOME ENERGY INDEPENDENT
WHERE THE STRAIT OF HORMUZ WILL
NEVER MATTER TO US AGAIN IN
TERMS OF STRATEGIC FOREIGN
POLICY.
THAT'S NOT STOPPING NADLER'S
NEVER ENDING SUBPOENA PARTY.
LOOKS AT WHAT HE WANTS NOW.
HE WANTS TO NOW PLANT AGAIN, TO
FORCIBLY INTERVIEW A BOAT LOAD
OF CURRENT, FORMER
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS AS PART
OF WHAT IS NOW THE FIFTH
OFFICIAL -- FIFTH OFFICIAL!
DUPLICATE INVESTIGATION INTO
WHAT WE ALREADY KNOW, THERE WAS
NO TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION OR
CONSPIRACY.
THE COWARDLY SCHIFF, THE GUY ON
TAPE COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIAN
GUY?
HE IS CONDUCTING A SEPARATE
SIXTH INVESTIGATION.
HOW MANY BYTES OF THE APPLE DO
THEY WANT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUMMED IT UP
PERFECTLY.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO ASK 12 MORE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SPENT HOURS WITH
ROBERT MUELLER, SPENT A FORTUNE
ON LAWYERS IN DOING SO
QUESTIONING HOW MANY BYTES OF
THE APPLE CAN THEY GET TO BEFORE
WORKING ON BORDER LOOPHOLES,
ASYLUM, AND MAY BE JOBS IN
KEEPING AMERICA SAFE, SECURE,
AND PROPER
, PROSPEROUS.
DO YOU WONDER IF THEY CARE ABOUT
ANYONE IN THE COUNTRY BESIDES
THEMSELVES AND THEIR PSYCHOTIC
RAGE AND HATRED TOWARDS TRUMP?
THIS IS BEYOND A PSYCHOSIS.
DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE IF THEY
BANK OF PRIVATE CITIZENS' LEGAL
BILLS BUT NOT ONLY DID THEY
TESTIFY BEFORE MUELLER, THEY
WANT THEM TO ENTER THE SAME
ANSWERS THEY'VE GIVEN TO THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE, SENATE
COMMITTEE, THE MUELLER REPORT.
HOW MANY TIMES -- THIS IS
HARASSMENT!
THEY SHOULD BE CARING ABOUT WHAT
IS A DESPERATE SITUATION AT THE
BORDER.
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT THE
SO-CALLED DREAMERS OR IF
THEY REFUSED TO SIT AND TALK
WITH THEM.
THE ONLY THING DEMOCRATS SEEM TO
CARE ABOUT IS SMEARING,
BESMIRCHING, SLANDERING THE
PRESIDENT AND DESTROYING ANYONE
AND EVERYONE WHO SUPPORTS HIM.
QUITE FRANKLY, THIS IS BEYOND
SICK.
A GREAT DEAL MAKER IS NOW IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
HE'S WILLING TO NEGOTIATE EVEN
WITH PEOPLE WHO HATE HIM WITH
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE ON SO
MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES TO MOVE
THE COUNTRY FORWARD.
TO HELP THE CARPENTERS, THE
PLUMBERS, ELECTRICIANS, THE
NURSES.
AND EVERYBODY ELSE IN AMERICA,
RAISE THEIR STANDARD OF LIVING.
IS THAT WHAT THEY ARE FOCUSED
ON?
NO.
THE PEOPLE IN THE LEFT AND THEIR
BUDDIES IN THE MEDIA MOB CANNOT
SEE THROUGH THE FOG OF THEIR OWN
RAGE TO SIT AND COME THROUGH THE
TABLE AND SAW AMERICA
SOUTH AMERICA'S PROBLEMS AND
MAKE AMERICA A BETTER, SAFER
PLACE FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN.
WHAT A NOVEL IDEA.
THEY ARE STILL EXCESSIVELY
TALKING ABOUT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES, HOAXES, AND LIES
THEY'VE BEEN PEDALING FOR OVER
TWO YEARS, AND A STACK OF
PRIVILEGED SUBPOENAS FROM THE
WASHED UP LAWYERS IN THE
DEMOCRATIC HOUSE.
LET ME GET BACK TO MY MONOLOGUE.
BY THE WAY, I HAVE ADVICE FOR
PEOPLE.
IF YOU'VE GONE AND COOPERATED
AND ANSWER THE QUESTIONS AGAIN